[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we had addressed
an example problem
on the circular plate which was
subjected to uniform loading
and it was clamped all around the
periphery in this video we are going to
consider a slight variation on that
problem
in the sense that we instead of a
uniform loading
on the circular plate we are going to
consider a
concentrated load at the acting at the
center
so how do we uh solve this problem so
uh first of all let us write down the
governing equation i will not
uh again repeat the the initial
discussions or rather lend the
discussions that i had in the previous
video
while starting out this problem rather
i'll start from an intermediate step
which was to consider
a uh consider the governing equation
so we had the governing equation in this
particular form
now please note that this q was like a
distributed load but here we have the
concentrator
so here directly we have a challenge how
to how to address how to how to
match this thing in this uh in this form
so uh what we do here
is so suppose suppose uh
let us treat it in an engineering sense
suppose we do write it like
f what is the harm here well you see
if we write like this uh first of all
there is the problem that this entire
governing differential equation
has to be valid in the domain
0 to r
well if that is so then it would appear
to us
that nowhere or wherever we are sitting
along this along this radius uh
this f would be acting that is what
would be represented
by this or that would be the meaning of
this governing equation if we had to
simply write it like this
but that is certainly not true because
this f is only acting at r equal to 0.
how do we represent that there is
another issue here
that this f has the unit of
newton if you go back to the previous
video
you should note that that q that had the
unit
of newton per meter square just like the
left hand side of this equation
this has the unit of newton per meter
square
so there again is a discrepancy on the
left hand side we again have the same
kind of terms
so that unit remains unchanged as newton
per meter square on the left hand side
but on the right hand side as written
this is newton
so how do we how do we overcome these
two discrepancies
first of all regarding the applicability
of this
f and second of second regarding the
units
so this can be solved by considering
the direct delta so if we write like
this
the direct delta of r up with the
understanding that we are actually
writing it like
r minus 0 what we actually imply here
is that this entire term will be
applicable only when r is equal to zero
okay anywhere else that you are sitting
on r
okay r by two capital r r by three
anywhere
other than 0 this term is going to be 0.
regarding the unit if we are saying that
this is indeed the correct expression
then it must mean that this dirac delta
has the unit
of 1 by meter square and that is
actually correct
because i mean it seems a little weird
to think of this direct delta having
some unit
but you see
usually we think of the direct delta or
uh
the definition uh in this fashion from
our
undergraduate days that we have this
thing
there are the direct delta is defined in
this fashion uh that the integration
from minus infinity to infinity
that is equal to one uh
what will be the counterpart of this in
the radial
or the or the polar coordinate system so
what we say here
is that
we have this but then we have to
actually
carry out the integration in this polar
coordinate system properly
and the counterpart of what we have
written above
would be by considering this kind of an
elemental ring
of radius small r and
thickness dr
and this integration will be from 0 to
infinity
and this thing will be equal to r now
you note immediately that
if you are considering the r to be
some sort of of a simple number
as part of of the of the real number
line then it certainly does not have any
unit
but suppose it were to represent actual
dimensions
then this particular part this has this
would be have the dimension
of meter square and then naturally
because this right hand side is
dimensionless this would be having the
unit of
1 by meter square and that is why when
we come
here this part has the unit of newton
the f has the unit of newton
the direct delta of r that has the unit
of 1 by meter square so overall this is
newton per meter square
matching with what if it is there on the
left hand side okay
all that is fine but how do we solve
this okay
so the trick is to really exploit the
condition that this right hand term is
indeed 0
at r equal to 0. so what we are going to
do is instead of considering this
governing equation which is
valid over the domain 0 to r 0 included
we are going to consider a slightly
different on
of this of the same problem
like this where we say that r
lies in the interval 0 to r but the left
hand side is
open okay so how does that help us
well you see the moment you have this
kind of an equation it is very easy to
uh well it is quite straightforward i
wouldn't say very easy but quite
straightforward to do the
integrations repeatedly in exactly the
same fashion
that you do that i have asked you to do
in the previous video
where on the right hand side you had an
extra complication in the form of that
64 beta
that is not even present so what you
will end up here
is you can immediately write down this
the the form of this thing as a
r square ln r plus
b ln r plus c r squared
plus d okay
now the question comes about uh like
what what should be the boundary
conditions
well we can immediately write down
whatever is happening at r equal to
uh small r equal to capital r the
problem there it is exactly the same
conditions as before
which is w is equal to zero and
dw dr is equal to zero so the deflection
is zero and the slope is zero
at uh at the all around the periphery
because that periphery
is clamped but again we are uh we have
to deal with the
with the with the condition or uh or the
quest question
that what do we do what we
do regarding the the other two
conditions which are missing
well just like in the previous problem
where we had the uniform loading we can
still argue for the fact
that w should again be finite
okay we have this form for the w we can
see here that there is
this rather inconvenient looking term
here uh
and we would very much like it to be
finite even though we have kind of
avoided
uh actually going to r equal to zero uh
but we still have to go to our uh
very close to zero uh and even then it's
a
this this term is problematic so
what we say here is that as
r tends to zero w should still be finite
and if that is so we can immediately
conclude
that beta that b must be equal to zero
so we are left with this term this term
and this term
okay so we have two conditions which are
yet to utilize
but we need another condition and this
is where the
the the real challenge of this problem
uh comes about okay so uh
what is that extra condition you please
note
that in this entire story we have
completely avoided
dealing with this applied force f
now that is the the prime mover of this
problem the prime driver of the entire
deformation
we cannot avoid dealing with it we have
to take this into account
so how do we take this into account so
uh so please do not think that
just like before we can we can get away
with uh
with imposing the condition that the
moment should be
finite we have to somehow incorporate
the condition that uh that this
f is is is influencing the deformation
so how do we how do we take take that
into account well you see there is a
little hint here
the hint is in the nature of this
applied load itself it is the
force f so what is directly connected
with this force f
well uh
you can start thinking about the shear
force
so if you think of the shear force uh
it's something like this
okay so what we say is
suppose you considered suppose you
considered
a
a part of this
okay a smaller ring
which is concentric with this circle and
let this be of some arbitrary radius
r please note
that if you look if you really zoom into
it
maybe this portion maybe this portion if
you zoom into it
you will find that that is actually
having a certain thickness which we have
integrated throughout
uh because of the way that we have
derived our
uh our governing differential equations
but that has physically a certain
thickness and over that
a a shear force
per unit length q is acting
okay so that is the qr
so what exactly is going on here or how
how can we
read how can we write this thing
properly in terms
of the the things that we have
written down in our derivations okay so
so let me go to the next page here
what i want to write here is that q
times twice pi r that should be equal to
f
so this q it is acting all around this
periphery which has the radius of r
so that length is twice by r and
no matter which uh no matter what radius
of this
periphery i take this should be actually
true the condition that i have just
written down here
q times twice pi r that should be equal
to f
okay so uh all that is fine
i mean physical understanding is fine
but what about the expression itself
okay please note that this is the qr so
this qr
it is actually corresponding to the qn
which we had written down during our
derivations and that
please remember was n x q x
plus n y u y
and this thing this q x itself
that is del m x del x
plus del m x y
del y whereas this q
y that had the form del m
x y del x
plus del m y
del y now
if we were to carry out all the
substitutions that would be
of course a little bit lengthy
so i i encourage you to perhaps uh do
this bit
using symbolic python and jupyter
notebook and in fact this is
this is another problem that i have
given uh in the problem sheet
so i won't go into the lengthy
derivations of this it is just uh
i mean you do have you have to do it
patiently or you have to do it cleverly
in
symbolic uh python uh or any other
uh computer algebra system but
eventually the expression that you
will obtain will be d
ddr of del square
w and which is
ddr and this del square w
this is the laplacian
so we have this thing
okay now uh
what we have to really do is to utilize
this con this expression back here and
equate it to
f well let's try this
we already have from our previous page
this expression for w
all that you have to do is to is to
obtain the expression
uh somewhat patiently here
so what i'll do is i'll go to the next
page and
carry out the
carry out the steps so uh
the first thing of course is that we
have to do this dwdr
that gives me twice a r
uh i don't need to consider this p
that is 0
and i don't need this d also
oh i think i made a mistake here i need
another term here because
this actually involves the r square ln r
so i need to write this as
er also because this lnr would be
contributing a 1 by
r next for
i should not be blindly doing this d
squared w d r squared because
you note that in the the previous page i
had this
rdw dr that's what i need i'll do that
twice a r square ln r
plus a r square plus twice
just twice cr square next i need to do a
ddr of this
so that gives me a 4 a r
ln r plus twice
a r plus another twice a
r from this term plus 4
c r
and let me just check
so i have completed up to this ddr i
need to do a 1 by
r if i do a
1 by r here directly so
that goes that goes that goes
and that goes and finally
if i have to carry out this last ddr
i'll end up
with
well this doesn't contribute this
doesn't contribute and this doesn't
continue because these are just
constants this is just 4a plus 4c
so i don't need to worry about it and
let us not forget
that this capital d is also present so
i have this term so uh
this entire thing is the qr
and the condition that i need to impose
here is q
r twice by r that is equal to f so this
gives me
4 a d by r
twice by r that should be equal to f
and this is very good that this r and r
cancels and
that gives me the expression for this
unknown constant
a as f by
8 by a
oh sorry 8 by d
all right so uh currently
uh i know about my b that is 0
i know about my a all that i don't know
is c and d
but for that i have my
my boundary conditions here at r equal
to capital r
so i can quickly go to that
so
this a is already known to me as i've
just found out
up so i need to just use that
r equal to r
w is equal to zero
so that should give me a r square
ln r plus c r square
plus t is equal to 0
furthermore at r equal to r
i have d w t r equal to 0
which means i can just go to the
previous page and copy out this
expression for
dwtr
i have to be careful that this small r
is actually capital r here
because we are sitting at the periphery
now
okay so these are basically two linear
simultaneous equations
involving the the unknown c and d please
note
that a is already known to us and
the second equation that we have just
obtained that is now
simply this involving this unknown c
a is already known here so now what we
can simply do here
is to write this as minus a
r ln r
minus half a since a is known to us c is
immediately known to us
and finally we go back here
this d can be written as
so in the interest of saving time i'll
not just substitute
this expressions of c and a here but uh
but the fact remains that
whatever we needed to find out we have
found out here so basically
this w is known to us now
okay so you see the two big challenges
involved in this problem was
to take care of the
of the of the governing equation uh
properly
and also the special condition involving
the
shear force on that note i will end this
video thank you very much